[Music]
um frozen does these on purpose to us
and frozen i haven't forgotten your
segment it's coming but frozen this is
on purpose so remember two weeks ago
when we did the black people water polo
thing
remember we were teaching black kids to
play water polo of course yeah remember
that was two weeks i remember last night
so many racist news articles lately
remember
people in water remember last week when
they were teaching black kids to swim
because they said too many black people
were driving the ymca i think in
cleveland or whatever
well we have a new one title of this one
all black hockey team showcases talent
hockey players they are the okay listen
he sounds shocked himself watch for many
black hockey players they
black hockey players first of all you
should never say many
black and hockey players all in the same
sentence we're gonna point something out
this looks like they're going to
commercial in the t's of the next story
yeah coming up next uh we're gonna have
the weathers might be a nice weekend and
uh all black hockey team coming up at
seven
[Laughter]
hockey players they will have more on
the january 6 uh subcommittee meetings
and black people on skates
it's all coming up next
black people on skates yes it's as funny
as it sounds coming up next at seven
hockey players they are the only
athletes of color oftentimes on their
teams but now
yeah he makes that face like how sad how
sad for those how sad for those city
people
a group of all black hockey players from
across the country is teaming up to
compete against some of the you know
what you call a team of all black hockey
players
best talent in minnesota in tonight's
voices for change maury glover shows us
how the panthers took the ice for their
very wait i'm sorry
they're the
black panthers hockey team no no no
royce rice all black panthers they're
the all black panthers hockey team birth
the original black panthers all black
panthers yeah but they didn't skate
first time this afternoon
it's
he's immediately [ __ ] gonna make the
same joke [ __ ] i hate you
i was gonna say i was gonna say he just
[ __ ] face plants
before you can ever play j.r ludke has
been playing hockey since he was about a
year old
i don't think one-year-olds should be
playing hockey i don't think that's
one
but this is the first time the
invergrove heights high school hockey
player has ever been on the ice with an
entire team of athletes who look like
him
this guy talks really weird
it sounds like his tongue is trying to
escape his mouth and he's catching it
it's honestly been a long time coming
like i never thought god the whitest
black kid ever
we're not talking to this i mean come on
yeah
well actually you know uh i'm just doing
this so i could have extracurricular
because i'm going to uh michigan state
university and studying robotics he's
probably going to usc
i have the experience too
just because there's not many
black hockey players in the world and
i'm just thankful and grateful that i'm
able to have this opportunity
the panthers are an old yeah there's not
a lot of white basketball players either
they're i mean we have some they're
called point guards
but even those are getting are gone
yep all black hockey team made up of 16
players from seven different states to
compete in the minneapolis 2022
this guy sounds [ __ ]
play summer showdown
[Music]
tournament at the richfield ice arena
this weekend
a pair of african-american hockey moms
from california put the team together
african-american hockey moms is
definitely the name of a ska band
really does sound like a band name yeah
together as a way for their sons to play
with other black 18 you players but why
this they can't understand though that's
correct me if i'm wrong here it is
joking aside like it's kind of cool man
if you want to play hockey play hockey i
don't give a [ __ ] of your black girl who
gives a [ __ ] right
but
but then these ma it's not they have to
be black they have to play with other
black kids why
because white people are evil look i'm
gonna make an i'm gonna make a
basketball league but it's only going to
be for white people to play with white
people it's going to be terrible and
they're not going to score
that's why the black people only want to
play with other black people so they'll
win exactly
white people to play hockey
talent and advance the sport in the
black community the more
we are seeing within the sport the more
comfortable you understand you guys are
making yourselves the stereotypes right
like it's not us that are [ __ ] the
joke around it's when you go like i know
i too thought it was crazy black people
don't like ice i'm like it was like
magic it was like sorcery
they go but coach why the water frozen
sir i'm like bro you're the news
wait so this light used to be water but
now it like it's hard are you telling me
when it gets cold outside the water
turns to like
your guys are
i am i know there's black people that
play hockey i've seen them do it
why are you turning into a news article
i get it it helps us for content i
appreciate it
but come on
and it's getting worse and worse you
know the next one's gonna be black
people doing math
like that's you know that's gonna be the
next one with these news people coming
up at nine
yeah exactly
within the space anthony walsh was on
the edina high school hockey team that
won a state title in 2013.
he says bringing an all-black hockey
team to minnesota is particularly
meaningful in the state of hockey where
the recent racial reckoning caused by
the murder of george floyd
what
how are we tying this into george floyd
well no if it was on ice he would have
just slipped away then he wouldn't have
worked
he was on way too much fentanyl to play
hockey yeah that's true
this led to an effort to make the sport
more diverse and include divorce
what is that
can we hear that again
more diverse
inclusive the images of black people
that you see
on the tv aren't always very pleasant
wouldn't that be their fault and not is
that our fault whose fault is i'm sorry
did this black guy just go black people
rtv are normally pretty scary
what is happening
[ __ ] christ
and this is what is more pleasant
especially in minnesota than the sight
of
a bunch of kids another
what is more pleasant in minnesota than
a bunch of african americans playing
hockey
i don't know a bunch of whites playing
hockey that's true
having fun and guess what they happen to
be black
no they don't happen to be black you
started it specifically so they'd all be
black this isn't a thing where like they
just so happen to have an all-black
hockey team on because of the of just
how the [ __ ] dice roll right this is
them looking for black people to put in
a hockey team
[ __ ] cool runnings again
the panthers inspire the next generation
of african-american children to think
about life on the ice in the future
showing that more black kids can play
hockey
and that it's not just a white person
sport we never thought
it's not just for whites anymore royce